what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading onto my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
story lines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on uh later on in this
channel okay so we are continuing our
discussion with Superman red Sun now for
those of you guys who are who who saw
the first video bear with me for a
second because uh there are probably
some people who are joining us for the
first time but Superman red Sun for all
you new folks was basically a story that
took a look at the idea of what the
world would be like if Superman had
landed in Russia after World War II
basically communist Russia as opposed to
the United States and the result was
that the world shaped up radically
different for example Jimmy Olsen
instead of being uh a member of The
Daily Planet was basically head of the a
government task force and eventually
head of the CIA Lois Lane was married to
Lex Luther uh it was a lot of these
things that that sort of changed up it
was really more like real world history
that changed in a lot of different ways
and and none more so than than what
happens here so uh Volume 2 basically
picks up 20 years after the end of
volume 1 so it's been 20 years between
the time that Joseph Stalin who had
basically adopted Superman after he had
landed in Russia at 20 years between the
time that Joseph Stalin died and
Superman took power to the current day
right now uh there are a few things
though that will change especially when
it comes to like the idea of Wonder
Woman uh Batman a few things like that
and we'll cross those bridges when we
get to it but at the moment right now we
basically deal with the introduction of
Brainiac now Brainiac as he's shown here
is not some great big huge grandios
thing it's actually pretty small with
the cool thing about this is that Mark
Miller draws on brainiac's history now
within the realm of DC Comics and this
is where where DC got the idea for
convergence but within the realm of DC
Comics uh brainiac's main thing was that
he would basically travel to different
locations he would shrink cities down
and then he would put them in bottles
and just treat them as trinkets things
that he would store for his uh for his
own purposes now the convergence event
basically dealt with the idea of all
these different realities that had been
stored in different locations and things
like that but uh the fact remains here
that Lex Luther had essentially made a
PCT with uh with brain AC with the idea
that Brainiac would basically go and
capture Moscow and put it in a bottle
and the reason why is because it would
basically allow the world to operate
without Superman you know if Superman's
city was captured if Superman was inside
he would be shrunk down and he would
basically just be in a perpetually weak
form and because of that it would have
you know essentially solve the problem
of Superman the problem with this is
that Brainiac basically captured
Stalingrad and because of this you know
Superman is essentially here realizes
what's going on and actually goes and
captures the head of Brainiac now that's
going to be wildly important it's going
to be the means by which Superman
implements this very uh totalitarian
rule but the fact remains here that for
Lex Luther he just looks at this as just
another failed experiment effectively
just another failed instance of trying
to defeat Superman and so what we do is
we pick up with Moscow proper now again
we basically have what the equivalent of
L Lang now again for those of you guys
who are new here L Lang was the
childhood friend of Superman in
Smallville in the mainline Superman
stories that is to say the main DC
Universe stories really in almost every
else world's publication to be honest
she's kind of one of those main State
characters that's always in the
background and Superman Red Son again
because a majority of this takes place
in Russia it's very very similar into
you know in terms of her role as a
person now the problem with this is that
instead of maintaining a friendship
that's still the test of time there was
a while where they just didn't talk to
each other in fact it was about 20 years
or so where they didn't talk to each
other between the time that Superman was
adopted from the ks in Russia to the
point that he just re-encountered her
after he began to take power uh but at
this moment right now for the last
however many 20 years or so uh that that
L Lang has been working as part of
communist Russia she's basically become
the head of like a tour guide I mean
that that really seems to be about it
but the basis behind Superman putting
her in this in this position was because
as a close friend he wanted to make sure
that she had the means to take care of
her kids so on and so forth and it's
basically a permanent job that she'll
never lose but she also fills us in as
the reader in terms of what's going on
and saying that over the course of the
last 20 years Superman has ushered in an
era of world peace never thought
possible but the important thing to to
remember about this is that he's
basically doing it at the edge of a Gun
there's actually a guy here who's going
through and touring he's kind of being
put in his place by basically a security
guard and this guard of sorts has a
device attached to the side of his head
again that's going to be important
that'll be a major focal point when once
we get to volume three especially
towards the end of volume two really
when we get to like Peter rosoff but the
idea here is that in real world history
to Sidetrack from the story for a second
in real world history in the post World
War II landscape we basically had the
Cold War it was a Mad Dash between
Russia and the United States to uh
expand their own respective spheres of
politics uh Russia or I guess the USSR
at the time wanted to expand its
influence of Communism and the United
States wanted to expand its influence of
capitalism now after World War II we had
the formation of NATO uh in response to
this the Soviet Allied territories
basically created something called the
Warsaw Pact and the Warsaw Pact was just
exactly you know in Alliance between
these uh these these communist Soviet
territories that was kind of like you
know their answer to Nato itself uh the
issue with this is that while Warsaw was
formed between I think it was formed in
1955 and a collapsed in 1991 or
basically was eliminated in 1991 uh here
in the Superman red Sun Universe it
never ends it keeps going on to the
point where basically it expands out to
the rest of the world the only two
Nations that are not part of the
Communist Russian regime under Superman
are the United States and Chile which is
kind of an interesting choice in terms
of Chile but the idea here is that this
guy who's basically kind of going around
and doing these tours is actually you
know the the Russian equivalent to Bruce
Wayne now again this is not wealthy
Batman this is not super rich Bruce
Wayne the son of Thomas and Martha Wayne
with billions in billions of dollars
instead this is just a ground level guy
who's just kind of operating as an
anarchist and that was actually a really
cool take to bring in with his character
more so than that when he goes to a
local bar and starts talking to uh the
barkeep as well as one of the people who
were there I guess a member of the the
Soviet guard he basically talks about
how he thinks Superman should go away
things are worse now than they were
before there's talk here and there about
how those who who plot Insurrection or
those who speak negatively about
Superman's leadership are basically
turned into Superman robots like that
guard we saw where they lose any real
measure of um of Independence and
basically operate in accordance with you
know complete adherence to the
ideologies the Superman is is laid down
in terms of you know the USSR in
relation to the rest of the world but uh
the idea here is that that Batman is
basically an anarchist and what he does
is he makes a public announcement
telling everybody I've put bombs in five
different locations and I'm going to
detonate all of them at the same time
anybody who doesn't want to die get out
that's really what it is there's no
major ultimatum there's no like give me
Superman or I'm going to blow these
buildings up it's just Anarchy in the
extreme and this is really what Batman
does and that's kind of the cool thing
is because historically speaking in DC
Comics Batman has always been this sort
of enigma and that's what he bases
himself on I mean we as the reader know
about him but in terms of the criminal
underworld they don't really know
anything about Batman they just know
he's this guy that swoops in whenever
they're committing crimes he beats him
up you know he uh he aggressively helps
them change their minds you know and
basically you know sends them off to
Jail uh with regards to the Superman red
Sun universe is very much the same way
some people think he's dead some people
think he's alive no one really knows
much about him and the cops just can't
catch him and it really makes the KGB
look foolish here a really good example
is after these bombs go off he's using
these these makeshift tools that he has
again because uh he's is not you know
extremely wealthy here but he's using
these makeshift tools he makes a daring
escape and he tricks the KGB into
thinking that he had jumped on top of a
car while he basically makes his getaway
now at this point we pick up with uh
with Peter rosof and Superman again
Peter rosof was the was one of a
multitude of illegitimate sons of Joseph
Stalin in this story and the idea was
that rossot was always kind of kept at
arms length he was put in charge of the
secret police but Joseph Stalin had doed
over Superman because of what he was
capable of the power he represented and
the fact that that Stalin viewed him as
an all of the might of Mother Russia and
so because of that rosof had developed a
lot of animosity towards Superman and
that animosity still goes on now despite
the fact that Superman put him in the
position of being the head of the KGB uh
the idea is still here that rosoff
doesn't like him very much now Superman
basically kind of bails out mid
conversation to basically go you know
save two trains that are crashing into
each other but a really important thing
that he brings up here and this is
really something that I've always
thought about with his character and he
basically says that if you were being
honest he's getting tired he's growing
bored of human conversation and that's
one of of the cool things about Superman
it's one of the things that I like that
Mark Miller addresses with this because
when we look at someone likes Superman
when we look at someone as powerful as
he is who has almost Godlike power in
comparison to your average human being
the question is why would he associate
himself with such lowly creatures if
you're a man that can fly bullets bounce
off of you you can move planets you can
transcend the barriers between
Dimensions why would you care about
people who can't do any of that why
would you care about people whose
greatest tool is their imagination I
guess um it really kind of goes to the
heart of the idea that in the Superman
red Sun story this Superman is again
very much different from the Superman
that we're used to the Superman that
we're used to is the person that
basically says that is the point people
do have imagination sure they can't do
the kind of things that I can but they
aspire to one day they want to one day
and that is why I spend so much time
with them because I'm kind of a guide
I'm a Shepherd moving them towards the
direction of a better future as opposed
to just letting them descend into
absolute Madness and you know deal with
whatever fate befalls them because of
their own actions and Ambitions and so
on and so this is one of the reasons why
Superman is such a pivotal character
just in the realm of comics because he
imbus the idea of what human beings can
become now at this point we switch over
to uh to Wonder Woman now keep in mind
this is one of the cool things about her
character is because you know sure she's
been around for 20 years or at least
she's you know been established as
Wonder Woman for the last 20 years or so
but the Justice League was never formed
because of the fact that the Justice
League was never formed a lot of the the
solo Adventures of Wonder Woman never
really took place instead she spent a
bulk of her life on Paradise Island
never really had a reason to leave and
so she never really explored herself to
the fullest in terms of her powers what
she was capable of that kind of thing
she does have a strong understanding in
terms of her abilities you know her
strength in comparison to an average
person but pushing her her very
definition of self to the absolute limit
you know finding her testing point for
you know her moral and philosophical
breaking points was just never really a
thing and so because of that what we're
told is that uh Paradise Island had
basically join the ranks of Superman's
uh regime and helping to bring equality
as he calls it to the rest of of the
world the the caveat to this is that you
know Wonder Woman is very much in love
with Superman I mean she is extremely in
love with him now this is kind of cool
with with uh with Mark Miller toying
with this because remember Lois Lane is
married to Lex Luther so Lois Lane's not
part of the picture he kind of you know
danced around it earlier in the story
you know in volume one when Superman met
Lois Lane for the very first time and
there was a brief connection and Lois
Lane was talking about how it felt like
they should be together but he basically
whisked off and the two of them never
really talked again and so because of
that you know he basically says if
anybody was going to get together it
would be Wonder Woman and Superman but
as we're going to see things take a very
very dark turn but for the most part the
Superman views her as a very strong
friend of his in the sense that he
basically says you know I will be here
whenever you need me you know hit me up
if you need anything and uh you know
yeah we'll kind of we'll keep our
friendship in that direction but the
idea here is is switching over to Lex
Corp Industries again with Lois Lane and
Lex Luther being married uh their
marriage is is strenuous and they might
as well not be married for all the value
that it has and and the reason for this
is because the Lex Luther that we have
here uh is very indicative of the golden
age Lex Luther where he is obsessed with
defeating Superman and that kind of
dominates his life I mean it dominates
his his every being you know he's
obsessed with beating the Man of Steel
and because of that he basically put his
marriage on the back burner so sure
they're still married you know in terms
of of name they're still married in
terms of the fact that she's still you
know Lis Lane Luther but in terms of
actually having a relationship that the
two of them care much about that's
really not there they spend you know one
night together every year for their
anniversary and even now Lex Luther's
kind of blowing her off now the reason
why he's doing this is because going
through every attempt to defeat Superman
there are people inside the Kremlin
really the main capital of Russia inside
Moscow that do not uh believe in
Superman's cause and because of that
they're basically sympathizers to the
United States ideology to capitalism and
so they're essentially working against
Superman from the inside feeding Lex
Luther information one of these
sympathizers had basically revealed Lex
Luther that if Superman is exposed to
Red Sun radiation he will lose his
powers now this is actually kind of a
cool thing here because we have not in
in the story so far seen a tried and
true true weakness to Superman instead
he's just been this guy whose power is
unrivaled and no one really seems to be
able to stand against him but again you
know Superman kind of takes us on this
on this monologue you know kind of
transitioning away from Lex Luther you
know Superman takes us on this monologue
where he begins talking about how you
know through his efforts through his
work uh he had basically gone through
and and uh more or less forced the
United States to to kind of join his
cause to a degree again they're not
fully on board but he saw himself as a
Messianic figure in a lot of different
ways when the Space Race happened and
there were space disasters he was there
alongside Wonder Woman to save him you
know save these these uh these
cosmonauts and and these astronauts this
is really what's going on here in the
sense that Mark Miller is continuing to
build this idea that Superman and Wonder
Woman are a couple in every way except
by any real official nature and so
Wonder Woman continues to fall in love
with Superman she continues to fall in
love with everything he stands for his
kindness his compassion how much he
cares about people how much he believes
he's doing the right thing in terms of
creating a more a more structured and a
more cohesive world now from here we
switch back over to Peter rosoff and
again you know Peter rosoff has been
talking about trying to find a way to
get a hold of Batman trying to find a
way to talk to Batman basically trying
to bring down Superman and the result is
that while he's being chauffered to you
know his next location whatever it
happens to be uh he's basically
kidnapped by Batman who's masquerading
as a driver and the result of this is
that he basically sits down and starts
talking to roslov now keep in mind
during his younger days as part of the
secret police roslov had killed the
parents of Batman that's one of the re
that that's really the reason why Bruce
became Batman in the first place so
there's a there's a lot of anger here
there's a lot of hatred here uh you know
for from Batman on behalf or I guess
towards rosoff but it's one of these
circumstances where it's like that old
adage You Know The Enemy of My Enemy is
my friend and so at this moment right
now Batman's willing to sort of put
their animosity aside for the purpose of
defeating Superman but he says you know
he says Point Blank you know have no
Illusions you know and I will make no
bones about it when Superman's defeated
when I've taken him down I'm going to
kill you not only that this also reveals
to us that the sympathizer inside the
Kremlin that's working against Superman
is roslov himself and so roslov was the
one that passed the information on to
Lex Luther that Superman's weakness in
terms of losing his abilities is red you
know red solar radiation that will take
away his powers and so because of that
you know while there's this celebration
of the Kremlin you know celebrating
Superman his his legacy there are a
series of explosions that go off which
of course kind of dot the landscape with
the Batman symbol uh but it's also
Superman coming to the realization that
Wonder Woman was supposed to be there
and she's not and so his idea is that
someone's taken her someone's taken
Wonder Woman of course he's able to
locate her and when he does he comes
face to face with Batman now this is one
of the coolest situations because
whenever we're used to seeing Batman and
Superman fight Bruce Wayne is calm he's
confident you know he basically goes
into this realizing if he just tries to
fight Superman with Brute Force it's
impossible he just cannot pull that off
the only real exception came by way of
the armor from you know the Dark Knight
Returns and even then it still took
green Kryptonite for him to pull it off
and so that's one of the reasons why
Batman usually comes out on top just
because of the fact that he plays it
smart that in the fact fact that he has
green Kryptonite if if Batman were to go
against Superman without green
Kryptonite he would lose every single
time I mean it's literally a man with
the strength to pull planets going
against a guy who's got you know
strength higher than your average human
being and so there there's no contest
there in terms of you know Superman
versus Batman but uh for all the bravado
and for all the talk of Batman he
basically comes out and he says hey look
you know I'm going to win one of two
ways I mean I'm prepared to die you know
he's he's got a bomb inside of himself
so he's like for me I don't care about
dying I mean I I intend to fully lose my
life at the end of this conflict whether
I blow myself up whether you kill me
whatever the case may be but I'm going
to take you with me and so what he does
you know while Superman is kind of going
through and and you know saying hey look
this is a waste man you you cannot
defeat me you're just an average guy
dressing up as a bat Batman kicks on
these red solar lights and then
Superman's powers just start Vanishing
and so right now it's just a straight
street fight I mean it's a straight up
fight and it's actually incredibly done
this is why people say the fight between
Batman and Superman and Superman and red
Sun is one of the greatest fights of all
time because there's no green Kryptonite
here I mean yeah sure there's red solar
radiation so that's the caveat but it's
not the archetypical fight it's not oh
and Batman's got green Kryptonite and he
wins you know it's it's not like that
it's basically two guys fighting each
other based on physical strength because
keep in mind if Superman is subjected to
Green Kryptonite long enough it'll kill
him with red Kryptonite it just takes
away his powers with red solar radiation
it just take away his powers and so the
idea here it's two men just fighting
just fist fighting but with Batman he's
fighting with passion he's fighting here
with makeshift tools you know he's very
much a poor man going against the
hierarchy here and that's really what
Mark Miller was shooting for this was
designed to be this sort of allegory
that that stands a test of time from the
dawn of man until the end of man you
know to quote you know KL marks there's
a spectre haunting Europe the Spectre of
Communism it's this idea of the the
proletariat the bisi the poor against
the rich you know this this situation
where it's just kind of like two two
opposing forces facing off against one
another each representing their own
individual IDE ologies so again because
of this Batman's basically able to get
the upper hand on Superman and actually
locks him down in a bunker immersed in
Red Sun radiation and because of this
you know Superman comes to the
realization that without the help of
Wonder Woman he's basically going to
lose here I mean there's there's going
to be no way for him to break out you
know he's going to be stuck down there
as a prisoner forever and so again you
know he basically communicates with
Wonder Woman and what ends up happening
is she breaks her own lasso of Truth now
this is extremely important this is a
very big deal because what happens next
is she grabs this you know this energy
device being used to keep these
batteries powered throws it into the sea
and then Superman emerges now of course
uh Batman says hey you know the one who
betrayed you was rosoff it's important
that you know that rosoff turned on you
but we also find out that Wonder Woman
has aged quite a bit now there is a
reason for this one of the big questions
that I've seen asked a lot people have
asked me on Twitter people have asked in
YouTube videos what happened to Wonder
Woman in Superman Red Son okay so here's
the deal uh Wonder Woman's lasso of
Truth has been gifted to her in
different ways depending on the story
pre-crisis post crisis different things
like that but consistently it's always
been a gift from the gods but in the
Wonder Woman Comics this is one of the
reasons why her her Godly Pantheon was
so popular in the Wonder Woman Comics
the gods of of her comics are the gods
from Real World Greek mythology and so
they have wrath they have Envy they're
very human in terms of their emotions
all that really happened here was the
gods had looked upon her actions of
destroying one of the gifts that they
had given her and so they basically
Stripped Away uh the gifts that they
gave her the the remaining gifts you
know her longevity her uh healing Factor
super strength her ability to fly
different things like that you know they
basically reduced her power in a massive
way and so she's no more powerful than
just your average Amazon that's the
reason why she looks the way she does is
because she no longer has her Eternal
youth so to speak you know she's
basically a normal Amazon and this is
how she would look as a normal Amazon
and so the kicker to all this the big
the big crazy thing about this and this
is what really kind of drives a wedge
between the two is that Superman had
constantly hearkened on the idea that
the two of them were the closest of
friends but in Wonder Woman's time of
need when Superman had asked her to
break her lasso of Truth and it resulted
in her losing so many of her powers
Superman doesn't care his only Obsession
here is the fact that Peter roslov was a
person that turned against him and so
because of this you know she looks at
that is though he had basically
abandoned her that he had basically
walked away from her when she needed him
the most now from here we pick up with
President Kennedy and with Lex Luther
now the conversation that these two were
having is the idea that Superman is not
the only extraterrestrial to have landed
you know on on the planet Earth that
prior to the arrival of Superman there
was somebody else that landed here and
the other person that landed here was a
Green Lantern now what they're doing is
they're basically just going through and
they're analyzing the body right now but
they also come to the realization that
there is a ring and that this ring
possesses incredible power through their
studies through their mechan through
their investigations they've come to the
realization of uh the the fact that a
person that possesses this ring and
knows how to use it is a person that
would be able to rival Superman in terms
of his abilities and so what happens is
this volume begins to wrap up uh with
the idea that while Batman is dead while
Superman had basically killed Batman uh
in Batman's place are basically a group
of Vigilantes called the bat men and so
these are people that have kind of taken
up his mantle and began working against
Superman and that's why I say you know
in previous videos that when it comes to
people who rule with an iron fist the
one thing they fear the most is a person
rising up against them just because of
the fact that even if they manag to Quil
that threat the idea of someone standing
up against an oppressive uh leadership
will mean that other people will be
inspired to do the same and so it'll
create this domino effect of more and
more people rising up against Superman
making his life as a leader absolute
hell and so again this is really Mark
Miller setting the stage and saying
here's what's going to happen in the
next volume here's how we're going to
see this conclusion unfolding with the
world that Superman's build you know at
least it seemed like is going to come
crashing down around him now the final
little tidbit here is that because of
the fact that rosoff was revealed to
have been the guy who betrayed Superman
Superman basically turns him into a
robot I mean he attaches one of these
obedience discs to the side of his head
and he follows Superman's ideologies
with absolute adherence not only that
because of the fact that Wonder Woman
had lost so much of her abilities she
basically turned against Superman she
had looked at him at looked at him as a
guy who wasn't a friend instead you know
he never really cared about her in the
first place and so this is going to set
the stage for the idea of Wonder Woman
turning against Superman and so as we as
we begin to bring this to an end the
last piece of information that we learn
or at least that we get is that Superman
is basically building a fortress for
himself this is effectively the Superman
red Sun equivalent or introduction of
this Fortress of Solitude kind of idea
but again uh if you guys are new here to
Comics explain make sure you guys hit
the Subscribe button to become part of
the Rob core if you guys are enjoying
Superman red Sun make sure you guys give
it a like we have one more more video
left until we are finished with red Sun
it's a is an awesome story I love
Superman red Sun but uh leave a comment
down below let me know what you guys
think about it so far because I I really
dig it I think it's an extremely
well-written Story one of the best super
R stories ever covered and uh yeah I
will catch you all later
[Music]
peace